hey Drew I'm a wife and a mom of four
I'm also a pet mom to a dog a cat and a
bearded dragon named Spike
spikes pink didn't fit in the living
room so we put them in my daughter's
bedroom on an old desk
I really want a functional and stylish
face so I can feel closer to my family
and pets we could do homework with the
kids I can feed the baby and I could
show Spike some love
from one pet mom to another can you help
let's go please welcome Christian
now obviously I was excited to do this
segment with you because there's Jeremy
that says yeah
so tell us more about your dragon design
dilemma
so it's tough when I'm in the kitchen or
with the baby we have a lot of you know
other things going on it's hard for me
to be in my daughter's room where spike
is tucked away right now and we want him
to be closer to us well and it's a big
tank like they need a lot of room as
they grow again when you get it it's
this big so you're like sure I'll take
that on and then you've got this thing
eventually this is not how I saw it it's
a good look though my life thank you oh
thanks I think you were saying that
Christine Okay so we've teamed up with
PetSmart today and two friends of the
show who have a new collection with them
please welcome
and Jeremiah
[Applause]
[Applause]
tell us about your Pet Smart collection
this is something that hasn't really
been addressed with a like a design
focus and a design lens and the idea of
creating these habitats for the some of
the most important members of our family
and making it a reflection of you know
the things that you have in your home
the materials and and the sophistication
that exists in the space around you yes
exactly you know what we did was we
brought our design perspective to every
category for small pets so you know the
furniture the things inside yes I'm very
excited about the furniture components
look at you guys
oh my
stars you want me to take Jeremy you can
I just want to make sure he's
comfortable yeah I'm gonna go stand over
next to it if you want to put it on
there no but we're really proud of the
of the entire collection because if it's
the blend of two things that we hold
really important which is Beauty and the
functionality component you can see here
um you know this piece it's got a faux
marble top it's impermeable it's got
clean lines brass hardware hooks for all
of the accessories that we know I'm sure
you've got plenty of storage like I have
never seen any approach like this in the
pet accessory world it is so Chic this
is the first time I'm seeing it I love
it do you think Spike likes it look at
it and look how easy it is to reach in
and out you just lift this up French
doors you need a French door a French
door I have a top and it's hard to get
up and over ridiculous this is the
answer well as you can see it was really
marrying what we love about design you
can see these finishes are all things we
use in people's homes but PetSmart has
the expertise they're the ones that like
you need hooks you need this you need to
have them the doors open in the front
the plaster hide you can see the hide
that they can like you know they they
can walk right up and they can bathe and
bask on top everything's like the fluted
plaster details for the Planters even
the greenery is something that we worked
on every single leaf to make sure that
it was absolutely perfect the wood hide
over here that feels like a sculpture
I hope Jeremy's very happy if you don't
think that I'm going immediately I'm
buying all of these because Jeremy's
tank doesn't look like this Jeremy's
tank looks a little bit like the set of
Rambo so Christy
um what do you think I think that this
is just amazing okay Kristy you're gonna
go home with this tank from PetSmart
with all the decor items and the stand
from the Nate and Jeremiah collection
and
PetSmart and our show are also going to
give you a check for five thousand
dollars so that you can achieve this
look in your home however you see fit
and there's more the entire audience is
going to go home with the 100.
everyone in the audience is going to go
home with a 100 gift card
[Applause]
s
[Music]